what is going on there reject nation koi just
showed up with his tony stark facial hair rushed
to pick him up because this trailer dropped
just a 15 minutes too late for us all right
guys leave a like he's the marvel expert he's
going to handle this i've got to do it so much
every night i dreamed the same dream
awesome
wow oh nice transition
that's sweet i did what i had to do
to protect our world you can't
control everything strange
you open the doorway between universes oh [ __ ]
we don't know who or what we'll walk through it
whole bunch of cameos
what do you know about the multiverse this
had his theories he believed it was dangerous
he was right it's just a minotaur hanging out
i'm sorry stephen
your desecration of realize
will not go unpunished oh [ __ ] oh dude like
ultron sentries we should tell him the truth
the trailer are you serious wow
oh yes just got out of here
that doesn't seem fair
can someone tell me what we just watched
no button this doesn't need it who needs
somebody don't look at that michael waldron
that's patrick stewart's that is unmistakably
his voice and the illuminati i want to sew the
villain i love it i love that she's got a
point and that's something we talked about
years ago with not wanting just like the mad woman
syndrome of like hey it's a little hypocritical
what are you doing yeah they're just calling out
in the trailer well the fact that they go so far
is to have her confront herself in a literal form
whether that be a multiversal variant or just her
you know in some kind of visual psychological
representation yeah and i love that we can have
even that gray area in a trailer like this and the
idea that he's looking at his heroic self while
she's looking at her villain self the dichotomy
of how he perceives himself and how she perceives
herself she sees it as grief he sees it as triumph
i don't care how you guys are processing so much
where do i jump in with this conversation
i i i think that this really demonstrated
sam raimi's direction a hell of a lot it's felt
a lot more like sam raimi film much more than i
even anticipated to actually feel especially at
the opening moments with all of its nightmarish
sequences a lot of them spinning shots that sam
raimi loves to do and the ins and whatnot who was
that person flying at wanda earlier on he said
captain marvel it looked like captain marvel i
thought no load nova because like the it's hard
to tell but it looked like it could be a helmet
with the nova symbol and the blue gold but it
also looked like a cosmic power-up so a cosmic
entity could fit either of those i really do
like the conversation that they're having it
looks like they're doing so much here it's like
you got america's chavez they always happen to
look after the multiverses and chaos that really
does seem like the the illuminat that would be
the illuminati definitely patrick stewart which
could tie into an incursion event which is how
they could tell the multiverse story so in the
incursion of it in the comics it's other earths
colliding from other universes if you've got the
concept of the multiverse colliding with your
universe and deciding which multiverses to take
out maybe taking out the fox universe in one giant
event deciding to save the mcu at the cost of the
fox universe but what did you guys not notice that
they have a new logo i mean that's they're really
i love theirs that's what i want to talk about
are bananas like the i didn't expect as much like
horror as feels like terrifying well yeah i mean
i that's something that was teased for us a lot
we have this thing with dr strange and it seems
like they're setting up that he is responsible for
a lot of the chaos that is happening while also
wanda has her own tampering going on as well
so it seems like that when wanda is recruited
or asked by strange to join in on whatever
this chaos is that she's going to find it as
an entry way to get what she really ultimately
wants like you know i think there's a reason
why she brings a vids again i think there's a
reason why we're going back to the house in one
division you know like she's gonna go see herself
it could be a psychological projection i didn't
think a lot of people really liked but then the
main hole that people were trying to point at me
was that saying that normal mutants could have
already happened it could have been some wanda
variant but they were like but she's a
nexus being the only our r wanda could
be the one who could do that no other variant
could do that but here she is hopping around
with other ones exactly she's acting in with
another wanda so i mean are we looking at a
scarlet like a different scarlet witch at this
moment we're also you know on mount wondagor
which is very famously a threshold that's close to
magic on the earth so if there was any tampering
with other things that's where you'd want to do
it that's where you'd mess around with centerac
that's where you'd mess around with chaos magic
and you've also got the idea of it looks like
strange doing another spell that causes problems
not the no way home one just one it was one smell
that's really going to explore the capabilities
of chaos magic and the repercussions that it could
have stretching across dimensions and universes
this looks like it's going to really deliver
to the point where i'm a little bit concerned if
it's going to be too much of a cacophony of chaos
it feels like no way home was the end of
something that was 20 years in the making
this feels like the launch of something that's
going to be the rest of phase four five and beyond
so is this something that's so big that it's going
to be irreparable like is this tearing something
will this end and have us go like okay much like
loki ended now we begin like how many beginnings
are there well you see it like i'm excited
that michael waldron is returning to wright for
this because he wrote the loki series and i
thought he did an amazing job loki's a lot of
people's favorite disney plush show i i really
love the hell out of it especially its sci-fi
existential psychological discussions that it
would have and i'm hoping a lot of that actually
does remain here because right now i'm like do
we only have time for a bunch of action scenes
because that's what you're going to show in
this training sure sure exactly and that is
like that was my concern as soon as it ended
i was like that's a lot but if you've got the
the market we have right now especially in a
post no way home world what else do you show
except for like we're just getting started like
they should have better than i thought they would
yeah yeah i'm surprised they they let
us hear professor x's voice there's a
mutant in the mcu in this trailer they
that's a confirmation who else would it
be i feel like that nexus being thing you
guys are trying to point in a hole in it
how would you how would you communicate i would i
would posit that that is a concept that was just
as feeble as what we saw with the infinity
gyms because hey things evolve things change
so i like your concept but uh it looks to
me like it's wrong and we all know how much
marvel loves to take things from the comic books
and then when they put them in the movies they
change them around yeah they were miracle children
they weren't called mutants you can't like decide
something for sure because this is another
universe this is another multiverse yeah you
can't compare the rules of the comics to the rules
of the movies so i wouldn't see her interacting
with another version of herself that would seem
like variants of wanda confirmed the way elizabeth
olsen's performance is at the end i'm like that
doesn't feel unless that is our version of wanda
who has evolved into something much darker by that
point in the movie you know i said jesus yeah i
said years and years ago the best way to bring
in the x-men was to do something kills the fox
universe like in the comics they do blank kills
the blank and i think at the end of the day an
incursion event with the illuminati destroying the
fox universe folding over things you want bringing
in the characters you want or not this is the best
way to do it if that's what they're doing they
were talking about when you're when you're hopping
around the universe or something that wanda says
that you're like a hero and there's like a statue
so one universe strange is really hailed as like
you are sorcerer supreme we love you and that was
the grief versus heroism we were talking about his
perception of his choices versus her perception
of her choices yeah yeah deep [ __ ] right and
let's go circus let's go circle it up this visual
effects were awesome tiny new fonts dr strange on
the surface the minotaur we were hearing rumors
that maybe there could be a character rich raw who
could appear in here you didn't see a face shot
so i don't know maybe also it wasn't really green
enough for me but hey it's a different universe
oh yeah they can fix that if you complain loud
enough guys that's how the internet works yell
about the color what did you think about this
trailer uh this was more epic than i anticipated
it to be like i was kind of surprised by how much
they showed us here they showed us so much they
showed us like act one two and three it feels like
they did here right this could be a mislead where
this is the opening and we do get an encouragement
this is the opening not the opening too much guys
big open no the first two acts i think this could
be an incursion event movie where you actually
see the marvel universe bring in daredevil type
characters from the netflix universe and bring in
characters from fox we never thought we'd see we
could see nick cage ghost rider in here this could
be all the things because what you could do is
you could literally have snapshots of different
universes all at once you could have howard the
duck from george lucas like you could literally
do 1986 through today you could do tv and film
and have it be just little cameos to appease the
people that want that but still tell the story
that is as in-depth as we were trying to make
this that you disagree with you know there was
no point in you showing up to your kids there's
none no incursion events they're coming no value
just had an initial thought for this post-credit
scene america chavez doesn't use magic she
actually has portal-based abilities so maybe the
way we're able to stabilize this universe at the
end isn't necessarily through the abilities of
the illuminati at an incursion level event what if
we're able to stabilize because we use portals
to go into other universes saving individuals
and also that might be the way we bring
in characters from other multiverses
safely instead of crashing them together what if
america chavez is our great savior in this we saw
a bunch in the trailer more than i expected hoping
america chavez is the one that saves the day
all right guys leave your thoughts down below
follow koi if you can wow that was overwhelming